how is she today what is her next move
she's right well her next move is appeal
amber heard's lawyer says she's ready to
fight back following johnny depp's
victory in his defamation trial against
her do you find that mr depp has proven
all the elements of defamation
answer yes elaine bredhoff told cbs
mornings that heard has plans to appeal
after the jury decided the actor was in
fact defamed by her awarding him 15
million dollars in both punitive and
compensatory damages and one of the
first things that she said when she came
back from the verdict when we went into
the conference room was i am so sorry to
all these women that said that yes she
felt like she had let down all of these
women because she had more evidence than
most people do and yet they still didn't
believe her it's a sentiment the actress
echoed following the verdict in a
statement she posted on instagram
calling out her disappointment and
feeling heartbroken
quote the mountain of evidence still was
not enough to stand up to the
disproportionate power influence and
sway of my ex-husband
i'm even more disappointed with what
this verdict means for other women it is
a setback it sets back the clock to a
time when a woman who spoke up and spoke
out could be publicly shamed and
humiliated it sets back the idea that
violence against women is to be taken
seriously has mr depp proven by a
greater weight of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard
answer yes
breth says that evidence was suppressed
during the six-week trial held in
virginia compared to a 2020 libel
lawsuit against the uk's sun newspaper a
case dep lost
and she believes in this most recent
case depp's celebrity played a major
role in the jury's decision but the
other problem is we had cameras in the
courtroom so here we had not only did we
have a group of depp fans that were
there every day a hundred were allowed
in they lined up at one o'clock in the
morning for their wristbands to be in
that courtroom but we had everything on
camera and we had tremendous social
media that was very very very much
against amber very was pointed out that
that was the first time that a victim of
sexual abuse had to testify on live
television and i fought hard and lost
that battle so it should not have
happened breth says the juror's verdict
sends a message to all domestic abuse
victims amber had an enormous amount of
evidence although a lot of it was
suppressed in this case as opposed to
the uk but look at all the women who
have no evidence all these women who
suffer from domestic violence domestic
abuse
they don't have evidence and basically
what this jury said is unless you pull
out your cell phone and you tape record
your spouse beating you
you're out of luck
[Music]
you